you may be under the impression that
so-called sweat shops where workers toil
for pennies are only found overseas but
in fact it's happening here too in los
angeles back in 2016 the u.s labor
department investigated and found that
pay violations were present in 85
percent of the la garment shops that
they looked into
now there's a bill to protect
california's low-paid garment workers
from wage theft and it's headed to
governor gavin newsom's desk our
consumer investigative correspondent
anna werner is in la's fashion district
anna good morning
good morning tony yes there are
thousands of those workers here in la's
garment district working in conditions
most americans would never accept and
almost no one sees them yet they're
producing some of today's most popular
fashions
[Music]
they're the clothes all over social
media garments called fast fashion
but behind the glam of many brands is a
chain that leads back here to la's old
warehouses fashion brands often buy from
a vendor and the vendor buys from
factories in warehouses like this one
just ask francisco zuul this is one of
the places you used to work right
exactly
he's spent nearly 30 years sewing
garments in those factories often called
sweatshops i'm looking the windows are
open so there's no ac in there there is
no ac at all
over the years zuul has documented many
problems while working in la's garment
industry like in this video he took of
cockroaches running rampant through one
facility there is some kind of modern
slavery going on and on the stretch ups
modern slavery modern flavor in the
swedish shops yes
modern slavery he says because workers
in those shops earn money on a system
called a piece rate they're paid for
each seam they sew each sleeve they make
each piece they complete
they
paid us like five cents
six cents for a piece
five cents or six cents a piece yeah as
a result workers average hourly wage
last year ranged from 5.85 cents to as
low as 2.68 cents according to advocacy
group the garment workers center
director marissa nuncio at those low
rates they can never
reach the minimum wage it's just it's
impossible even the most seasoned
skilled workers
cannot sow fast enough how fast would
they have to work to make the la minimum
wage of fifteen dollars an hour a worker
paid five cents per piece would have to
sow 300 pieces in an hour
it's really fizzy for me it's very
difficult says this worker ver hilda who
only wanted to be identified by her
first name because she fears retaliation
she's worked in the garment shops for
over 20 years but says she still earns
less than five dollars an hour
if you ask for a pay raise she told us
they say if you want to work then work
if not there's the door
we wanted to see the conditions for
ourselves so we went with francisco zul
to a building where he used to work
visiting a different factory you are the
owner
inside no air conditioning as workers
sewed or trimmed stacks of inexpensive
looking clothes
we asked shop owner valentin carbajal
how much would someone get paid to make
that but the the company paid me maybe
around seven fifty seven
oh seventy five so the company pays you
around seven dollars and fifty cents for
this garment
carbajal told us with brands paying so
little for the garments he can't afford
to pay his workers much are you saying
that you can't raise their salaries
because
you're not getting paid enough
this employee maria told us she makes
200 a week so you're saying sometimes at
the end of the week you don't even have
the cash to pay the workers
yeah
that's why last month francisco zul and
other garment workers rallied in
california's capital to push legislation
to make brand name clothing companies
who control pricing not just the
subcontractors subject to increased
liability if workers aren't paid what
they're owed we have to make the
liability go to the brands state senator
maria elena dorazo sponsored the bill
we have to make sure that they are fully
responsible for what the workers who
produce their garments are getting paid
but many brands have fought the bill
saying they do follow the law and
shouldn't be liable for illegal
operators who don't the california
fashion association's ilsa met check let
me ask you a question that should be
asked of these factories if they cannot
do it legally and legitimately why do
they even take the order and most of the
brands we contacted said they insist
that workers be paid at least minimum
wage
but what they say isn't enough for
francisco zul he wants brand names held
legally responsible we accept whatever
they have to pay us because we need the
money we need to survive we don't have a
choice we don't have a choice
the california chamber of commerce
opposed this legislation calling it a
job killer they say some employers may
choose to move out of state to avoid
that liability provision the governor's
office would not tell us whether he
intends to sign this bill but there is
some good news this morning for
francisco zuul
thanks to the help of the garment worker
center he got a new job he's now making
minimum wage he says for the first time
working in this industry in 30 years
nate
very revealing sometimes the cost of
high-end fashion is so much more than
what's on the price tag anna thank you
so much